people who used to run Twitter are in
some hot water because Twitter files
part two was just published Barry Weiss
is the the person who published it you
saw the first part come out from the
journalist Matt taibi new one from Barry
Weiss
the type of journalist that Elon Musk is
hiring to go through this
is an interesting choice
if they are liberal journalists who have
some problems with the liberal left
they're not conservative journalists
that he's giving it to but he's giving
it to the the liberal what used to be
called the intellectual dark web type
kind of people you know the
I'm a liberal but I'm not a leftist you
know I'm that sort of thing but they are
still Libs I mean they are still on the
left they just are are sick of this
corrupt establishment and all the
extreme radicalism that we've seen in
recent years so Barry Weiss goes through
it
she does a bang-up job
she says the new Twitter files
investigation reveals that teams of
Twitter employees build blacklists
prevent disfavored tweets from trending
and actively limit the visibility of
entire accounts and even trending topics
which is bad enough but then they also
do this all in secret
without informing any users this is an
important release not because it tells
us that Twitter was Shadow Banning and
blacklisting people
we already knew that
but it's proving
just like with the first Twitter files
release
the the main takeaway here is not some
big news item that we didn't know about
before the main takeaway here is we're
not crazy
we are not crazy and the things that we
suspected were happening for years
actually were happening and the people
who were running Twitter and their
propagandists in the mainstream media
were lying to us
the people who run Twitter who told us
this this wasn't happening they weren't
just getting it wrong they were
interesting competent it wasn't just a
mistake they were actively lying to us
they were deceiving us
so who did they get
Dr J bhattacharya
Dr Jay bhattacharya very serious
Stanford scientist who from the early
days of covid argued that the lockdowns
were harmful
and that they would ultimately harm
children Twitter put him on a Trends
Blacklist so at the outbreak of covid
when when it was really important to get
as much information out there as we
could to try to take on the virus
one of the
credential lab coat wearing experts
who was much more correct about kovid
than Dr fauci or anybody else he was
blacklisted
that information was suppressed it is
not going too far to say
people's lives were upended and ruined
and
and people died because of this because
this information was not allowed to be
put out there because it was suppressed
by political actors uh then of course a
lot of conservatives were blackballed
Charlie Kirk was put on a do not amplify
list Dan bongino was put on a search
Blacklist so with Charlie Charlie is
absolutely great at Twitter and his
tweets would have a huge amount of reach
just the way he writes them his
personality he's just great at it and So
eventually they said okay we're just
going to suppress his tweets Dan bongino
who's got a huge rage
you couldn't even look him up you
searched for Dan bongino he wouldn't
even pop up and then here's the key
in 2018 Vijaya Gaddy who was the head of
legal policy and Trust to Twitter she's
the one who made the call to ban Donald
Trump when Jack Dorsey was out of the
office she said that the duly elected
sitting president of the United States
can't have a voice in the Public Square
Vijaya Gadi said
we do not Shadow ban
and we certainly don't Shadow ban based
on political viewpoints or ideology
that was co-signed by kvon bake poor who
is the head of Twitter product
so these are two people at the very
highest level of Twitter who said in
writing we do not Shadow ban and we
certainly don't shout a band based on
political viewpoints or ideology
we should have known them those of us
who didn't know I suppose most of us did
know but everyone should have known them
oh they do shadow bear when you say we
don't do this and we definitely don't do
it in this specific way then you are
acknowledging well we may maybe we kind
of do that first part a little bit no we
don't Shadow Dan and we definitely don't
do it on political viewpoints Well turns
out
they did
say shadow band they specifically Shadow
band based on political viewpoints
and at the very highest level there was
a team to Shadow band but then there was
a team above the team to Shadow ban and
who was on the team above the team to
Shadow ban
the jayegadi and Jack Dorsey they were
the ones making the highest level
decisions on who to Shadow ban a
practice that they lied about and said
did not occur they called it visibility
filtering
visibility filtering is just a euphemism
obviously for shadow Banning and
apparently Twitter uses this quite a lot
according to one of the Twitter
Engineers that that Barry White spoke
with quote we control visibility quite a
bit and we control the amplification of
your content quite a bit and normal
people do not know how much that we do
so next level stuff an outright Lie from
Twitter
and the thing is to quote George W bush
fool me ones shame on you fool me twice
the point is you're not gonna fool me
again
words of wisdom words to live by
when the Liberals clutch their pearls
and they say oh it's so terrible these
right Wingers there they're taking trust
away from our institutions and our
democracy
they don't trust
the big Tech oligarchs they don't trust
the
bureaucrats in Washington they don't
trust our elections they don't trust are
scientists in the lab coats think it's
so terrible why well why don't we trust
them
it's not our fault that we don't trust
those people
it's your fault it's their fault
we don't trust the medical establishment
because of Dr fauci because he lied to
us we don't trust the big Tech oligarchs
who control the Public Square because
they lied to us we don't trust the
people who are running the elections in
2020 and 2022 for that matter in certain
places because they lie to us and they
upend all the rules and then they
Gaslight us and then they relieve
themselves on our legs and they tell us
that it's raining they're the ones who
did it
okay
you lives you libs are the ones who did
it
so I'm not going to
shed one tier I'm not going to make one
single apology for not having faith in
the institutions that you control
okay we're we're not the ones who
destroyed our sacred democracy you are
okay you're the ones we are responding
and the only rational and prudent way
that we possibly can do not believe
these people
oh the media oh my goodness how did I
forget the media
the real news
and the neckties and the New York Times
and I know I sound like I'm doing an
Arlo Guthrie song in The New York Times
And The Washington Post and the CNN
right we don't trust any of them they're
complete Liars we they have no
credibility whatsoever if I see a
headline in the New York Times and CNN
in the Washington Post and I see a
headline on frogs turning gay
news.biz.co.uk I am going to believe the
latter of the latter has more
credibility if I see Dr fauci telling me
something about medical science and I
see an African witch doctor wearing a
big headdress doing a rain dance telling
me something about medical science I'm
going to trust the latter he has much
more credibility this is fake headline
Friday I need your help
to help me beat Ben Davies he has given
me four real headlines one fake headline
I need you to help me get this headline
correct so head on over right now if
you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]